gang let's talk about that middle class
famous tour baby coming to a town near
you the hottest thing on the road right
now we've been zipping all over the
country and we're coming to a town near
you kippy straighten them out first of
all we got a second show out in chicago
sold the first one out yes we did zany's
still some tickets left for the late
show then we're over there in rosemont
tickets are moving for that so get them
goddamn
then we're also going to be in
pittsburgh buffalo and detroit get them
now before they're gone yeah stand-up
show we play ayg with the crowd you've
seen the clips what are we doing come
see us bring the homies bring the bozos
bring the squad do it welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage uh-huh it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it if they go to be classy
yeah or they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host dave trolley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at antodi's basement i had to lock
her in her room yeah when she saw this
specimen coming down the side of the
wall i'm gonna have to shop back the
bathroom out again
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of are you
garbage he's international businessman
and he is not to be trifled with in the
boardroom or the bedroom give it up for
kj kevin james ryan hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
cooking baby we've been saying that
since about 300 subscribers and they
really are cooking now that's the hustle
uh and then obviously the greatest
website of all time www.patreon.com
backslash are you garbage or slash rd
garbage check it out you get bonus
content episodes of hard feelings live
streams the whole nine yards check it
out oh yeah and having a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
give it up for t-bone mcscruffin toby
mcmullen everybody what's up dudes
what's up t-bone nothing we got the most
intimidating man that we've ever had in
the room
dude we've never had vegetables in here
now we got the cauliflower here
[Laughter]
trying to dial it back man yeah you
could be wearing a dress i'd still be
scared i don't give a [ __ ]
cause gang we couldn't be more excited
to have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time he is a very
funny very successful stand-up comedian
podcaster and former ufc fighter you've
seen him in but not limited to love and
sex ghost adventures we're going to get
into that
please do it kill tony chelsea lately
miss busters that's a check mark right
there
ancient aliens uh below the belt
something's burning watch what happens
live tiger belly 30 for 30 lights out
with david spade ridiculousness the joe
rogan show he is of course the host of
the fighter and the kid co-host king and
the sting he has a brand new special out
right now called gringo poppy but the
big question about his mind today is
could i take him
get jake paul on the phone couple milly
we'll find out do me a favor give it up
for brenda job everybody
let's go look at you
[ __ ] man's man i told you man
out of all the shows that i have on the
press tour this is i was looking forward
to this the most thank you buddy
dude and you guys need to hear this
everybody loves you guys
thanks i'm telling you from the from the
big boys across the board everybody
loves you guys thank you thank you thank
you thank you yeah you talked to my
girlfriend and my family they disagree
with you and i like how you said you're
not intimidating you walked in here and
started drinking the props from the set
well is that real skippy and just
[ __ ]
just a [ __ ] i'm doing keto
i'm keto man
is these random [ __ ] things up here
yeah he really went for you i'll do
whiskey i'm like all right we're just
talking about looking around casing the
joint like you guys got anyone there you
go right there yeah jamison too i forgot
about it yeah i don't know if i'm
garbage but i'm definitely an alcoholic
i mean i was jonesing to get your
whiskey well first of all we didn't even
ask him if he wanted to drink we had a
bottle of water out and he goes you guys
just pound water is that how you podcast
i'm like
i think there's some turpentine in the
corner if you want to you guys want to
put a little hair on your chest huh
what is so packing a lip right this
guy's going yeah nicotine not tobacco
nicotine
yeah were you on the dip at one point
though the real deal oh really yeah i
never get real deal these are i don't
know if anybody dips in here but as far
as like nicotine goes like the flavor on
these man i like everything's intense
coffee like i start my mornings with
eight espresso shots i do i do i go
through a can of these
yeah take a walk do some push-ups or
something
[ __ ]
yeah and i only eat red meat
really yeah like a big cat at the zoo
if a tiger doesn't eat it i don't touch
it fellas so yeah so i'm gonna have a
heart attack in about four years so yeah
that's enjoy enjoy this
enjoy the content i have four years to
get good at stand up
i feel like i'm sitting down with a
liver king
this guy's crazy what is the backstory
what what's the what's the origin story
you're a colorado kid denver kid uh
really aurora aurora colorado right yep
so man no one's ever asked miss uh
have you been podcasting for like 15
years
literally it was me no one's ever asked
me where i've been never nobody asked me
anything
ever i'm always doing my own [ __ ] so you
were a fighter who told you that yeah
like who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] gave you
that info
this guy actually hasn't been famous for
a decade
oh man this kid's on edge i like it
this guy's a real loose cannon man i
think it's the espresso shots in the
morning when he starts choking out
t-bone i'm gonna let it go for a couple
of minutes
just enjoy the show
the espresso and the red meat's not
healthy
holy [ __ ]
salad
you splash in ct i forget where i'm from
dude yeah i'm like oh [ __ ] they're gonna
ask where i'm from everybody's been
punched in the head fourth house
got that working for me so that's cool
uh no
you're really gonna go yeah oh it's
gonna be a [ __ ] show
no i uh born and raised in aurora
colorado
aurora especially especially now but
when i was growing up uh mainly
predominantly black neighborhood okay it
was me my older brother uh black uh
divorced parents okay black neighborhood
so that's where
comedy and uh
sports kicked in right because in order
to be cool and fit in i got made fun of
me got bullied a lot uh-huh but um i
excelled at sports and was able to like
break the ice with anybody i'll make
friends with anybody yeah you put me in
a room i'll make 100 friends because i'm
good at like breaking those barriers and
like making fun of myself so that's
where the comedy and like all that came
from were you all were you big as a kid
or were you no i was small super late
bloomer really never got in fights as a
kid wasn't the tough kid
i was the silly class clown and then uh
i was athletic though but i was small i
was small super late bloomer so that
this is i don't mean interrupt you no
please please this is uh how serious
shows yours sir
just don't power bobby we're all right
someone take the
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
somebody turned on the microwave and he
freaked out
jesus is great we got a hot one already
boy super hot bros
yeah so this south seriously was about
um
fitting in at school so i knew
that i was more athletic than a lot of
those kids and at recess is where you
were cool so we always played on grass
with this soccer football and i had a
gift just at sports it was a curse a
blessing and a curse but my way to be
cool you know they would make fun of me
but when recess came i would shine and i
knew that's how i'd get street cred so
uh my mom
we didn't grow up rich my mom i made her
take me to payless shoe stores and i i
wore a uh the mcgregor's at the time
cleats sure there were the mold cleats
dude i wore them at recess no hold up i
wore them to school so i'm walking
through everyone's making fun of me it's
going clink clink clink clink wait till
yeah i know it's 8 a.m
all right i look like an [ __ ] in
chemistry we'll see what's up yeah we'll
see what's up so recess came no one had
like good footing because it was like
you know
your your boy here
crazy i was barry sanders in fourth
grade dude
it might have been the cleats but then
the other dope thing my mom loved is
because they're mold cleats i'd wear
them on black you know black top and all
over is they wore out over time so i
didn't need new shoes so she was like oh
yeah you just keep wearing those and
they turned into regular shoes wait so
you wore run down spikes or cleats as
for two years yeah yeah mcgregor's yeah
yeah man but dude when when i attracted
real single mom [ __ ] right there yeah
when i had traction though we'll see
who's laughing
dude on field day
[Laughter]
[ __ ] breaking ankles over here that's
[ __ ] michael phelps of the field
damon dude where it cleats to school
that's a [ __ ] new one right i do love
the confidence like just [ __ ] i'll
tell you i'll take the beating right now
just [ __ ] way up fellas we'll see
what's up
walking around the lunchroom in full
football gear yeah
oh i got i black on
how did you guys
how did you guys end up in this
neighborhood
uh your family from the area yeah how'd
you end up in denver your parents were
yeah my parents uh yeah yeah uh no one
my dad was born in denver okay so he
just stayed there he just stayed there
and then he met my mom there and then
you know they got divorced when i was
like six or seven so then my mom moved
into an apartment and then my parents
were now you know i'm a dad i have a
six-year-old and two-year-old and when i
think of this the mag to what the the
pressure they put on me with my brother
when they get divorced
they sat us down like all right you got
to decide right now oh i had that job
who's coming with me who's coming your
mom yeah and my brother's like i'll go
with my mom and i'm like i'm staying
with dad so they separated and then we
would switch so i'd go to my mom's
monday wednesday friday and then uh
and then my brother would flip-flop whoa
swapping rooms and [ __ ] yeah nightmare
yeah that's a crazy fighter that's wild
yeah weird i used to fight grown men in
a steel cage in my underwear and i
didn't stand up comedy yeah yeah
[ __ ] making sense dude one bad break
and i'm [ __ ] jeffrey dahmer yeah i
mean oh yeah how how what's the age
different you and your brother he's two
years older and you guys went to the
same high school say same everything but
you went to the same high school we're
living in separate houses essentially
yep exactly did he wear cleats to school
or anything like that
he's in the marching band obviously yeah
yep dude my brother he had uh he used to
beat me up so bad like everyone if you
have brothers and sisters yes the older
brother 100
get all that that's fine that's normal
he would beat me up so bad like uh i'd
be outside again i'm not an aggressive
person despite what you guys think and
the way i look but uh i would just
whatever you say yeah in the 45
knockouts whatever man yeah
yeah say that to merco
yeah no but uh i was just uh really into
like saturday night live like that was
my thing man that's that was my goal
but my brother just had horrible anger
issues and i'm sure everyone has anger
issues but brothers was so bad the
divorce compound on top so i would uh
just be chilling he'd take a golf club
or a bat and beat me with it what yeah
so we had to go to anger management when
i was like eight or nine
and that was the view but yeah my dad
brought us there and even then the [ __ ]
i'm the one getting hit more of this you
gotta ruin myself your pants wouldn't
stop like they didn't know how to stop
it because he's out of control damn he
took my head and rammed it into the
fireplace so even now people think it's
from fighting but it's from my brother
when i was younger my parents like you
don't need stitches i'm like that makes
sense yeah
so what's he doing now uh he's my uh
tour we're great now growing up it was
tough tough stuff jesus yeah tough stuff
but he was he was the best he should
have been the fighter uh-huh dude yeah
he got a textbook yeah he on this so
many fights and like our first day uh uh
fifth grade for me first day of sixth
grade for him we lived like
maybe you know half a block from the the
middle school and then uh my elementary
school was like maybe i don't know half
a mile so
he would go earlier i'll never forget
this first day of school he left right
i'm like have fun loser and then i left
i don't know 45 hours later i'm walking
i see him walking back what the [ __ ] is
he doing and he had blood all over his
shirt
he's like yeah i got suspended i'm like
it's been 20 minutes it's literally been
10 minutes
my parents had to go up there and what
they found out is because he had uh
glasses and uh braces so they made fun
of him he wasn't like me he didn't put
up with it he'd fight back so this kid
was making fun of him you know he didn't
know the kid so he sucked the kid in the
face this is six great suck the kid in
the face kid goes to the ground and my
brother's holding the milk he had like
[ __ ] you know just regular [ __ ]
two percent melt and [ __ ] head kicks
the kid like teeth everything blood
everywhere milk [ __ ] shut up so he had
suspended for like i don't know [ __ ]
four months or something like that i
don't know what the milk had to do with
the story but i like the influence yeah
it's awesome
he dumped it on him now what's
impressive is he had a melt and was able
to
punch the kid and still kick him in the
face that's what kind of savage you're
dealing with dude didn't spill one drop
of my nestle's quick either yeah dude
you also say milk very trashy you say it
like him yes with an e milk well also i
have a speech impediment so be cool man
gibby that was your first warning okay
that's strike one man [ __ ] turn the
ac on in here
yeah
let's move the whiskey yeah holy [ __ ]
what did your dad do what'd your mom do
uh
my mom was like a property manager
bounced around
um my mom's crazy but it's also where my
i get my economy from is my mom like my
mom would steal
like shoot steal
with you there or like she with me there
she would do uh we'd go out a restaurant
and she's like she didn't have a lot of
money so she'd get paid
and we'd go to chili's i grew up chili's
was like our [ __ ] del friscos
and i my thing was i would get a full
rack of ribs which is the most expensive
item on the menu and a chocolate shake
that was my that was my celebration i'll
go there right now if my special hits a
minute
so i would do that every time when my
mom would let me do it and then uh
i would know if money was tight she's
like let's get the chicken fingers buddy
yeah yeah yeah and so i remember she's
like order whatever you want you want
two of them like sure she's like you
want two shakes you want extra chairs
i'm like oh it's mom's balling yeah and
then the check comes when i was like
okay cool so um i'll meet you up front
right i'll pull the car around and then
uh you guys just when you're done you
meet me out there but i was a kid and i
was like sure
she probably gave paid gave the money
and went to the car no she just did dine
and dash for the longest time dude holy
[ __ ]
anybody ever catch you never
really she was back to mom with the two
kids or the kid you know yeah that's a
good cover expecting like teenagers or
whatever is that why she had you wear
cleats
hey listen when you hear the gunshot go
those cleats get a little slippery on
that chili's floor a tile floor bad news
yeah what are you doing when you're
wearing a cleats jesus why would you
wear plates to chili's
we're trying to rip off a bowling alley
idiot what are you doing stuck in the
revolving door dude that's wild
wild butch but my mom is the reason
where i'm at where i'm at now because
sure every saturday man you know she had
uh robin williams on the tv all the time
who i looked up to for so long and then
saturday live was like my north star
yeah i grew up on all the old school
saturday night live and she forced me to
watch that so saturday nights like my
mom don't get it twisted she might be
crazy but she was [ __ ] the best mom
as far as like watch this be into this
so every saturday no matter what i was
doing we would watch saturday night live
that's awesome the chili's thing that's
[ __ ] great that might be one of the
wildest stories we've heard dining dash
with the kids yeah we're telling her
i'll meet you outside like they didn't
even even make sure you got out there
she didn't like let you guys go first
she was like [ __ ] it's every man for
themselves go meet me in the burger king
parking lot in 20 minutes i love that
that's hardcore that's a great story and
what about your pop what'd he do my pops
was it's a pursuit of happiness
sometimes i'll tear up when i tell this
story but my dad was uh
uh never missed
you don't have to go into it
this kid's on edge yeah
he's gonna hit me he's crying he's
really flaring out man
i start hugging you calling you dad
you pull out a golf club i'm running
no but my dad never missed a football
game nothing monster monster of a dad
super disciplined he's where i get my
work ethic from it's great the one thing
that drives me nuts is
you know it's not a bad compliment
people go he is the professional
athlete's work ethic no dude i have my
dad's work ethic yeah it's
i could be working at chipotle i'd have
the same work ethic that's just what i
know my dad's a monster but uh
we grew up in a super modest house like
two-bedroom in aurora colorado and my
dad was super smart so he was selling
like computer programs at the time and
he got about [ __ ] early late 80s 80s
okay and he would go door to door like
pursuit of happiness he'd have a
briefcase he'd always have a suit on man
looked like he was always in a fashion
like always looked like a [ __ ] dime
piece and you go dota dora selling them
and sometimes me and my brother would
follow him
and then uh
he sold um
some uh software okay the software and
then i remember on the phone
he was on the phone and he was jumping
around and he's he's jumping around and
i'll never forget the cord was all
tangled around him and he's like we made
it he made him
i just got chills and then two days
later
he had a printout of all these houses
because which one you guys like
what was the material what happened
what was the matter what would happen he
sold uh he sold his uh like the the
thing he was working on this big
computer thing okay sold at some big
company
damn and that was it you guys had made
it where everything worked out yeah yeah
and then uh i didn't know what was going
on because i was young and i was like i
like that one i thought he was just i
don't know yeah you know i was like i
like that one you remember my dad just
pulled a slip and fall into tgi fridays
yeah i'm like really this one
i'm wearing cleats
now what are we stealing from this
hashtag yeah
we're we're robbing houses now
we got to bring mom onto this can we
stop and get a chocolate shake he uh
yeah i didn't know i was too young so i
was like that one then two weeks later
we pulled up to the house he's like you
and your brother go pick a room yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome man it was
like pursuit of happiness all right yeah
my dad that's all right all three of us
gonna be crying in a minute a bunch of
[ __ ] over here i apologize man no
comedy
how fatty was the house
uh
it's interesting right because he still
lives in that house and at the time you
know i didn't grow up in that
environment it was at the time it was
like to me the home alone house it was
the biggest thing i've ever seen okay
now i've made my own way you know a lot
of credit to my dad and
you know now that i you fit three of
those houses in my house so it's like i
go back and i'm just like damn this
isn't that was crazy well so yeah the
perspective of like you're in a two
bedroom
this this house ain't [ __ ]
step your [ __ ] game up sell some more
software dork let's go hate it
yeah
can't even park my cars here set your
goals higher man
oh my god that's wild
all right let's get into a little bit
here
do people ever come on here and tell
that weird stuff or i [ __ ] this up
that was beautiful what are you talking
about that's the show baby [ __ ]
fantastic what was the pet situation
growing up was there one
any lizards
snakes birds name keep going tarantula
are you serious i'm an animal i was like
[ __ ] steve irwin before he died
i didn't [ __ ] with stingrays but i uh
[Laughter]
i was fit him in the pool yeah can't let
me talk to you about helix mattresses
you ever heard of them have i heard of
him i made boom boom one in in last
night
kids knocking boots on the helix didn't
hear a thing upstairs no neighbors
weren't complaining about that he got
the quiet life was
[Laughter]
do yourself a favor and take the quiz
take the quiz two-minute quiz yeah find
out how you sleep who doesn't have two
minutes sleep cold they'll straighten
you out man they'll set a mattress right
to your door for your specific needs
yeah me and the lady dude where's match
with the twilight mattress uh best
matches i've ever had first adult
grown-up you know big boy mattress i've
ever had it's fantastic best sleep of my
life so if you're looking for a mattress
take the quiz order the mattress that
you're matched to comes right to your
door ship for free you don't ever have
to go to a bozo mattress store again
nope uh just go to helixsleep.com
garbage like i said two minute quiz
match up with a customized mattress give
you the best sleep of your life plus you
got a 10 year warranty you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk free
that's over three months they'll even
pick it up if you don't love it but like
i said previously
i'll give it the kj stamper of approval
you're gonna love this thing helix even
has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away he looks his offering
up to 200.
200 clams 200
bonzos whatever you need uh and two free
pillows for your listeners at
healixsleep.com garbage one more time
helix.com that's garbage do it yeah kip
bespoke post are you talking about box
of awesome i'm talking about the box of
awesome i'm talking about that it's
springtime wouldn't it be nice for every
month to have a box of cool stuff just
show up at your door i'm talking
grooming materials things for your home
bar things for outside stuff for outdoor
use you're going to be out you're going
to be getting around in the spring and
you want to be flexing on people and you
want to look cool
some cool [ __ ] [ __ ] it's a cool guy
[ __ ] you never know you need it till you
get it yo i [ __ ] need this get
yourself a box of awesome do yourself a
favor it's unbelievable and guess what
most of the things that they get are all
come from small businesses how about
that so you're helping out the little
guy it's handcrafted material here
curated each box is valued at over at
around 70 but you only pay a fraction of
that price
uh it's free to sign up you can skip a
month at any time to get 20 off your
first buck your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome dot com
enter the code garbage at checkout you
know it that's box of awesome dot com
promo garbage for 20 off your first box
one more time write it down boxing balls
dot com code garbage do it i uh my
favorite movie was ace ventura
big time i missed a full week of school
and go see it at the movie theater my
mom just let me miss school and she took
me to work there's a movie theater
across her work so i just ditch every
day and go see ace ventura six days in a
row like a savage but um
i was that movie i i was always into
animals and then i had every animal you
know geckos [ __ ] tarantulas rept
every i had a bird that somebody gave my
mom and i was like can we keep it she's
i guess
they gave it to us because this thing
this thing was getting free birds that's
crazy dude it was
she stole that for sure right
you're right she just stole a bird she
stole that bird from the zoo because it
wasn't like a peacock like a it was a
[ __ ] bird dude it was a a huge bird
like he's got a toucan in his room yeah
yeah i think it was a peacock
but we didn't have my mom was like we're
not gonna cage for it put in your closet
i'm like that makes sense at eight so i
had in my closet but this bird had anger
issues so he'd come in and just attack
him he's in a closet dude yeah yeah
yeah so well then one day i was sick of
getting attacked i just left the closet
open the front door open he was just
like later losers and then
you bought the house next door yeah yeah
holy [ __ ]
yeah so i loved animals
you have normal dogs cats anything had a
fish so yeah man so i had cats when i
was a kid and uh i've always had really
bad allergies and they were so bad to
the point where they took me to the
doctor and the doctor's like yeah we did
all the tests we can't figure it out man
the doctor goes hey real quick uh do you
guys have any pets and my mom goes yeah
we have three cats and he goes an
and we have a ostrich
aggressive ostrich
he's in the closet though he's all right
he's in the closet so he's cool for the
most part you have a kangaroo with a
drinking problem
we have a couple koalas
no
nothing nothing
i didn't know this was your backstory
this is fantastic yeah so uh the doctor
goes uh and he has allergies even the
winter and my mom was yeah all the time
he goes yeah right uh so you know the
algae season doesn't exist in the winter
he's allergic to your cat's dumbass my
mom's like oh
so they found i was super allergic to
cats still have the cats
no well they kept them for probably
another year and then my dad just hated
him and then was like oh they ran away
and then about a year ago my dad another
year of allergies another year your face
is healthy
oh dude run it off i couldn't see like
go outside in your cleats [ __ ]
but i uh
about a year goes by and i did love
those cats and then my dad was like oh
they ran away they ran away i'm like oh
it's terrible and about two years ago my
god dad remember when those cats run
away oh they didn't run away i took them
to the uh to the where we walk at night
the park and just let them go jeez
that's savage [ __ ] yeah that you did
that happened a lot in the 90s oh yeah
animals just got whacked or let go why
now you can't do that [ __ ] i think
parents back then knew that if you took
it to the to the spca they were just
gonna put it to sleep and like you know
our parents generation had that you know
fend for yourself mentality and in their
eyes it's like i'm going to let them
free back into the wild yeah they
thought let them do it yeah for them
definitely better definitely not you
know because there's coyotes out there
[ __ ]
my mom we had uh gerbils and i went on
vacation with my dad
and my mom hated the gerbils so she uh
just let them out it's gerbils they do
nothing they live in an aquarium
they used to piss and [ __ ] all we were
like
no we would let them out and [ __ ] it was
bad okay so she set them out in the
backyard thinking like that we'll just
go die or whatever live and then we came
home and she's like oh listen the
gerbils died we were like ah [ __ ] you
know and then like three days later they
made it back into the house we're like
peanuts on the tv like [ __ ] they're
flourishing yeah my brother is killing
it yeah
my brother for whatever reason because i
was the animal guy and then he was like
oh i had a hamster this cute he's my
favorite hamster named eddie he was my
favorite man he's all fat favorite
hamster trashy statement also named
eddie trashy's neighbor
hamster named eddie he's my favorite and
my brother he's a bookmaker too
dude eddie the hamster is a mob
so go see eddie the hamster
sad to pay eddie the hamster right yeah
what did he uh
he's an actual hamster yeah the actual
hamster man eddie was he from the bronx
no it's just a hamster from petco but he
uh
my brother for whatever reason was like
i want a hamster and we go and i was
like this guy's [ __ ] stealing my
vibes yes
jacking your [ __ ] dude dude so we go to
the pet store dude he's in this fight
this is my eve this dude this is my evil
brother he picks out uh it was the on
every is this white hamster with red
eyes
so he picks out this rat with red eyes
and he goes i want this one even the the
person selling the animals like
really yeah that one's half off yeah
so
dude this it gets dark you guys asked
for it so uh he puts the hamster in and
my brother's like yeah he's a friend now
don't you want that i'm like yeah that'd
be good for him because he's lonely my
brother he's lonely
so i go to school the next i come home
and i look in there and uh his
rat now you brought that to light his
white rat with red eyes ate my hamster's
face off
god of course it did man yeah dude
had he gotten with the wrong people
and he should have paid the vig yeah so
eddie is no longer with him rest in
peace eddie eddie yeah way to go jay
wait the other one wait is jay your
brother or that brother or the wife
that's what was his rat's name
i don't know it's probably something
stupid because he was so into like
michael jordan emcee hammer she's
probably like you act like that's a
thing people are into together you know
he's into michael jordan m c hammer you
know
sir mix a lot ain't eddie yeah dude i
thought the first left turn was going to
come at the cage fighting yeah that
would be the craziest thing about you
yeah that's not the army not the
armadillo in your dresser drawer yeah
i thought the peacock you grew up with
in your closet was gonna be the weird
thing here for your demon older brother
jesus jesus christ that's insane dude
holy [ __ ] i was gonna ask you if you
know how to use chopsticks
this guy comes in bat in a thousand
sorry
this is fantastic what about the
vacation situation as a kid what would
that look like
not a lot of them we drive around
we'd
hit the highway for a couple of miles
and then pack it in and go back i-25 in
denver but uh
i'd like to read that report in the fall
when you go back to school how was
summer vacation and we drove up a little
bit we drove around no
we it was only road trips yeah regional
road trips yeah we'd go to uh like utah
because my aunt lived there
um
in the summers i grew up in venice beach
because my uncle had a house there so we
would go out to venice beach a lot
that's cali and cali that's pretty
classy all right
drive or fly you ever been to venice
beach
yeah but especially especially in the
90s it's probably probably you ever seen
american history acts or white men can't
jump still that's why
it's on the coast but it you know it's
yeah it's not the good i'm not the only
one with a peacock
place is wild yeah yeah especially in
the 90s yeah no that makes sense would
you drive there or fly
you'd fly there yeah okay
when did you get your passport do you
remember
[ __ ] i got my passport
probably senior year high school because
we went on we went to cancun for uh
senior trip that's good that's nice
first time i've ever drank okay really
passed out woke up with a tattoo on my
ankle okay oh man what is it i had to
get a tetanus shot it was a like it was
like a bar code
barcode tattooed on you yep and i didn't
know i woke up next morning on my butt
you know everyone got drunk and i go in
the ocean i'm like god damn my ankle's
killing me dude i looked down i had like
all these numbers on it i think they
were going to sell me in the sex
laboratory
and i like to think i would go for
pretty pretty top dollar i mean they
don't put receipts on them i don't think
i wasn't this big at the time but you
know i was still a diamond still doing
all right had acne i'll give you that
i wasn't a 10 but i was close he was 50
off what do you want
i didn't look like the kids from
euphoria those kids
[Music]
what about lunches as a kid did you pack
your lunch did you buy your lunch in
high school had la uh had lunch at the
school okay so my favorite was peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches because they
put extra peanut butter on them they did
they were wild but once they made it to
cafeteria ours were triple deckers yeah
and it was it was one sandwich of peanut
butter and one thick band of jelly they
were phenomenal
nobody really [ __ ] with them i super
like i was the one fat kid where i would
see peanut butter and jelly like yeah
yeah get all jazzed up over the [ __ ]
yeah because i love it i love the thick
peanut butter with the jelly like
there's barely any jelly all peanut
butter i'm a big pizza sometimes i'll go
just peanut butter i don't care
chunky or creamy you chunk your creamy
yeah i like chunky but it's okay i'll go
either way i grew up on creamy though
it's okay um so that was my favorite and
then i then i would uh either ask a
buddy or trade them i'd trade like
whatever the dessert because i love the
strawberry milk so i used to always
drink the strawberry yeah i hated that
[ __ ] are you a strawberry milk guy what
the [ __ ] did you say
to me
he wants to drop a line of his own
greatness yeah yeah exactly of course
you can use an sm right now i'll tell
you that right now
uh jobs as a kid
jobs as a kid uh my first job ever i was
a janitor i was a janitor at a at a
grocery grocery store 16 yeah
yeah before that i had my own lawnmower
lawn mowing business kid's a worker yeah
i i drew out my own business cards it
had uh george jetson on it mona lawn
because i like to draw i can draw a
little bit okay said george jetson on
there and then i'd go around to the
neighborhood mowing lawns where'd you
get the mower
uh it was my dad's okay yeah it was just
yeah i think the money for yourself
right shirts off in the summer yeah not
too bad brings all the boys to the yard
sun's out guns out baby uh what'd you
get on your sats yeah how were you as a
student uh in high school i think i
graduated like a 3-3 3.3 really double
double major in college whoa yeah
where'd you go to college uh you don't
see colorado damn yeah that's a good
school yeah yeah double major graduated
the whole nine yards yes or the two
majors uh business and sociology
all right it's an educated man here this
guy you're like a renaissance man do it
all baby i guess man hmm what was the
first car growing up first car was a
truck ford f-150 red really used
yes paid for it yourself uh down payment
that my dad would help me out from time
all right not too shabby man what was
the name of the supermarket you worked
at and did your parents shop at that one
yes they did it was in albertans that's
all right i was a janitor they treated
me like [ __ ] and then i uh
i knew i was going down a weird road
because you know you remember back in
the day when they had like the candy
just put in like five cents and take
whatever you want yeah i would uh
grab all the candy in the world because
i love candy sure i have cavities now so
i can't eat it but i would i'm not
getting them fixed but i would grab the
candy it's a weird statement we'll get
back to the candy why aren't you getting
your cavities fixed because i'm such a
sugar fan like i grew up like i'm
addicted addicted to sugar but it hurts
my teeth because of the cavities but i'm
losing weight so i'd rather lose weight
and not get the cavities fixed
so you would eat because you would eat
candy because if you got them fixed you
would go back and yes
psycho mentality yeah i like it
holy cow what's your favorite candy
everybody's gonna hate me after this uh
favorite candy uh
this is where i might be a serial killer
i love the good and plenties the the
pink and white good and plenties whoa my
mom's english so i'm half english my mom
was born and raised in england so i love
english candy black licorice the wine
gums you know all that [ __ ]
pastels all this likes good and plenties
and owns peacocks i don't know yeah they
have yeah are you are you a hair bow guy
yeah i like here yeah the the bags of uh
but what i do with those is i leave them
out so they get stale i like them real
hard that's why my teeth are [ __ ] up
whoa
like a shark that's why i have richard
ramirez's teeth
i love how like you wear a professional
fighter you've been punching the head
thousands of times and like all of your
injuries are not from that
like my teeth are [ __ ] up not from
fighting yeah gummy worms
do you like how many kids do that 15 not
from fighting from slipping on the
[ __ ] tile wearing cleats yeah
jesus god damn gummy bears that's wild
you like pizza yeah but only a month old
did you have a go-to frozen pizza
growing up uh totino's
99 cents okay combination that weird
fake sausage and the little uh square
cuts of the pepperoni i don't hate it i
think two of them those dunkaroos grew
up on dunkaroos hunkaroo's in the packer
in the box the little pack right right
yeah
the individual
beautiful we're not rich
and then i would uh the toaster strudels
now i would take an ass kicking for this
because my brother loved them as well
but i love icing when i say i like sugar
you don't understand so i would take six
icings put on one toaster strudel then
my brother would wake up and i knew it
was gonna be a fight and i'd lose but it
was so worth it
i enjoyed i enjoyed that thick icing on
that toaster jewel like you wouldn't
believe dude it was worth every ass
weapon i've been against your brother
until right now if i roll into that
freezer and you would eat all the icing
i'm beating your [ __ ] out of you too
so aggravated holy [ __ ] but i like how
you're like [ __ ] i'll take the
beating i have a guy who's been beating
your ass like i don't care it's not
that's [ __ ] worth it let's go bring
it on toaster with no icing
that's the thing he hits me over
i just saw the fighter show come out he
was like what the [ __ ] hackie
did you play did you play sports in high
school yeah
lacrosse and football nice yeah very
good did you have any aspirations of
playing in college
yeah i play at university of colorado
you did yeah four years football yeah
jesus christ yeah when you start why did
you why don't you start dropping your
winery university two years in the jv
squad
he's always [ __ ] reliving the glory
days until a real athlete comes in and
you're pretty mum's the [ __ ] word
over here [ __ ] d1 athlete
yeah i was a walk on there and then
earned a scholarship after a year yeah
god damn and then i and then from there
i went um
to uh the nfl i had a uh a cappuccino
with the buffalo bills
i literally was on the team as long as
anybody here was
but what's a cappuccino like he had a
drink
really quick it's really a quick shot of
cappuccino like we're all set on slow
white guys that makes sense
but you were technically on the bills at
one point the buffalo bill went to
training camp buffalo bills god damn
holy [ __ ] bill's mafia i apologize for
the hacky sack
yeah yeah that offended you
you're lucky he doesn't shove you in a
locker right now
we're into dodge ball
[Laughter]
too busy making out with your girlfriend
how's your tetherball game what's your
thoughts on freeze dad
red light green light
[Laughter]
how good were you at red rover red rover
uh i got one more on childhood uh what
was the name of the mall that you
shopped at growing up where you would go
hang out two of them was aurora mall and
buckingham all right with which they
sound pretty good but uh not really good
so aurora mall would be well known
because that was the movie theater at
that mall that was connected to the
shooting including a dark knight so i
grew up around the dark knight
what's interesting about that is then in
my childhood apartment that my mom grew
up in
across the street literally right behind
right where we lived behind us was the
chuck e cheese that was also shot up by
nathan dunlap who went to my high school
yeah wait he went to your high school
yeah he was older than me i was a kid
but
shot that place up and then the guy who
got shot in the
face and pretended he was dead and then
escaped came to my apartment's mill pond
and then that's when they called the
cops and all that [ __ ] happened damn
damn holy [ __ ] it's also [ __ ] chuck e
cheese right
that mouse goddamn mouth [ __ ] i didn't i
haven't ever looked at the origin story
of chuck e cheese
no i don't know why it's out there but
it is dark really oh my god i think i
did just see something like this on the
internet not too long ago yeah it's a
dark storm yeah yeah uh-huh i guess i do
know now yeah i do it does does ring a
bell yeah okay let's talk about titan
tight and tight and tight that cool
little investment app that they got over
there when they take the guesswork out
of it they do it for the experts because
i don't know what i'm doing i don't know
what i'm doing wouldn't it be nice
instead of going to reddit or going here
going to there trying to catch the next
thing have experts do it for you then i
guess what titan's the answer yeah you
go to experts when you want something
done right you wanna you're in a
high-class meal you go to a high-class
chef you're not cooking hot dogs in your
apartment no like a bozo no not at all
so why would it be like that when it
comes to your investments your crypto
your this your retirement the whole nine
yards that's why you gotta check out
titan as everyday investors the cards
are stacked against us we've been given
access to this marketplace of stocks but
we're competing against institutional
investors with unlimited resources guys
that went to harvard i know then they're
going up against me yeah fox business
school graduated 2.3 gpa giuseppe's
employee of the month 1999. uh growing
your long-term wealth isn't something
you can just do yourself and it
shouldn't uh and you shouldn't so just
sit back and you shouldn't just sit back
and shoot for average returns with titan
you have a personal investment team that
researches and invests for you so that
you can aim to outperform the market
while giving you court side seat to
become a smarter investor along the way
what are we doing if you're out there
playing a penny stocks whatever get
involved with titan even if you're not
let them do it what's going on here uh
check out titan if you want to aim to
become the smartest wealthiest investor
you've ever been it's not saying much
for me because nope i've been fleeced
every time i've tried that's why i'm
with titan now so head to titan.com you
get free 50 to invest with titan you
must use this url or you will not get
that free 50 bones do it uh and they
won't know that we sent you that's 50
bucks when you go to titan.com garbage
you'll invest with titan one more time
titan.com garbage invest with titan this
is a paid partnership with titan at the
time of the publication i am not
invested in titan strategies uh what
about now
talking about the house you make a
couple of bucks you do all right for
yourself you got a lot of jobs you wear
a lot of hats you do pretty good
pool yeah
jacuzzi
how many car garage
three-car garage three-car garage now
can you fit three cars in there now or
is it filled with [ __ ] no you can fit
three you can pull in three cars what's
the whip these days what are you rolling
around then uh i just saw something this
is where i'm gonna lose the fan base i
uh
i'm a huge car guy okay just a little
you know background here i grew up again
my dad pursued happiness sure his goal
in life was to own a 911 porsche so in
our living room was a framed picture of
a 911. so that was my north star yeah
don't be ashamed of being successful
yeah you [ __ ] busted your ass you
climbed out of a roar are you kidding me
yeah
i walked onto the goddamn buffalo bill
[ __ ] wild
don't act like you haven't earned it
here yeah so uh as soon as i as soon as
i could four to nine eleven i bought one
something like that just to burn it
yeah
i bought one and blew it up
take that dad yeah yeah it's full of
cats
[Laughter]
in your brother's rack who's winning now
yeah no uh so i bought a 911 i could
afford it at least that
but now i i grew up going to car shows
i'm a big gearhead so now without you
know i'm super blessed so now i have a
uh
uh f8 ferrari spider i have a gt2 rs the
richest guy you know horseshoe [ __ ] uh a
g-wagon 63. that's a tax write-off
that's for irs nasa martin in a uh ford
bronco a brand new ford bronco holy [ __ ]
what do you whip around in though if
you're running my daily driver yeah my
daily driver is the ferrari right now
yeah you're rolling around l.a in a
[ __ ] ferrari let's go baby holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] awesome
to be f i work
super hard you do not have to do nothing
but but back to that back to my dad um
when
so i don't know if you know how ferrari
works so let's say you we do not yeah
i i i've seen i've seen magnum pi i'll
i'll tell you how kia works if you want
to know that i'll school you on kia
because i got a i got a nice forte
maybe there was a gear head in here but
uh
so let's say one of the four you want a
ferrari you can't go into the fry deal
and buy a ferrari you have to be
allocated the ferrari now you can you
could if you're a billionaire you can
buy it but the markup the the the market
for them is so high so if you want to
fry you can't get a msrp the only way to
get a msrp is for ferrari yes and
there's a waitlist it's around probably
10 years to get on the list so i bought
a ferrari
probably six years ago seven years ago
and i put my name on the list because
you have to be a former owner of a friar
to get on the list so i bought a used
ferrari nothing great just use ferrari
put my name on the list it was like yeah
in 10 15 years let's be lit hopefully
i'm still doing well i can afford it and
then uh
now i'm good thanks bye
sorry things aren't going well
that's a tough call to field
you're sitting in a two-bedroom
apartment sorry my mom got caught
stealing i had to bail out i can't
afford it click no but i uh
i was doing a show at uh la jolla comedy
store in sand in la jolla we love it
there's one of my favorite clubs first
time doing it personally one of the best
clubs
that means nothing it's insane i don't
know what it is it's crazy it's good
times
the stage is great the room's great the
staff is great the best one of my
favorite nights of comedy i've ever had
yes one of my very favorite clubs so
i'm there i don't know like a year ago
and i do the the meet and greets after
the shows this guy comes up he has like
slicked back silver hair dope ass suit
nobody wears shows to my you know suits
to my show it's just i'm like what the
[ __ ] happening and he's talking to me
and he goes your car guy right oh yeah
big car guy he's oh what's your favorite
and i go my favorite car ever made is a
gt-2 rs he goes oh those are cool yeah
and he goes uh you ever driven one oh
yeah i own it man it's my favorite car
i'm never getting rid of it did you have
driven a ferrari you got to fry his
front engine though and i'm talking
about it you're not my favorite man
cause that's a shame oh yeah they're
cool though but you know i'd rather have
a porsche goes oh cool man and i go but
you know i'm waiting to get on the the
list i heard it's like a 10-year waiting
list because that's [ __ ] tough man
all right say less dude he leaves
again i asked to be on that list you
know i don't know seven years ago i'm
driving down uh somewhere in san diego
my brother's in the car and uh we're in
my bronco and i get a call and they go
hey it's uh uh ferrari north america you
got uh allocated a ferrari you got
pushed to the front of the line you
allocated fry
that guy was the head of ferrari north
america and he was the biggest fan he
was just a big fan yeah so i got
allocated i didn't know this the way it
works is when they allocate your friday
there's such a wait list you literally
have like five minutes say i'll take it
take it and you gotta have yeah you
gotta have all that cash on you yeah so
i called my business manager like dude
listen i gotta buy a ferrari right
it's an investment we can flip this
thing in a year like but either way i
gotta get it done he's like i guess man
you know so
got it done and then uh do you get a
choice of what kind of ferrari you get
they go we have this it's coming off the
boat from italy and it's just do you get
to choose no other way because you just
want your foot in the door so you're
gonna take whatever because once you get
that you can go to wherever the next
allocation and is it that year's model
yeah it's a brand new one brand new at
msrp
so it just so happened if i were to buy
a fry and design it myself to a tee it
had if i was design it it'd be this
exact cause i got lucky and got the one
because my favorite color in cars is uh
like uh dark green like british green
because my mom's british so i grew up
loving dark green cars so it's a dark
green ferrari which you never see with
tobacco leather and it's the spider so
it's a convertible
so it was literally it was just so
strange
so uh
when i and then they're like all right
it's gonna arrive in whatever six weeks
so i called my dad and i go hey i booked
you a ticket on this day it was for what
i go don't ask you're gonna see your
grandkids and i got something cool to do
so my dad arrives he has no idea why
he's there
and we drive down to san diego to pick
it up in san diego so we're driving down
my dad's like where the [ __ ] are we
going we're arguing the whole time like
god damn it me and my dad are like two
[ __ ] siamese fish man we get together
like especially when politics and covet
we just fight yeah so we're fighting the
entire way i'm like would you just shut
the [ __ ] up
yeah so we get there and we walked on
friday what the [ __ ] and they have my
car there with a like a veil over it
like a red veil and i go i bought this
dad i bought from telling jokes on stage
what you told me was a bad idea i bought
this [ __ ] ferrari from telling jokes
on the road man jesus and they [ __ ]
ripped it off and he was just like
my dad's not an emotional dude and he
was [ __ ] that's [ __ ] [ __ ] would
you make him ride the bus home yeah
i'm taking
well i had a great time in the ferrari i
made it in 20 minutes yeah that's wild
what about boats you got any boats no
boats helicopters bad investment yeah no
it's all about investment smart with
your money he is right so i see yeah
right yeah votes for money yeah a
ferrari isn't about a car a nice car is
an investment
this kid's [ __ ] i'm telling you right
now flying first class i assume
good man good man if you had to choose
between a slurpee or an icy what are you
going with oh [ __ ] i love both of my
son's balls deep in slurpees right now
okay that's all he wants
the original slurpee's nice
oh man the coca-cola slurpee this is a
tough one coca-cola i see nothing to
shake a stick yeah i'll take icee though
i grew up on icee yeah okay my son likes
slurpees now those seven elevens are
dicey dude that's that's why i never
even i got a ferrari up front
even as a kid i didn't like to i didn't
like the slurpee just because the
7-elevens were so dirty the 7-elevens
are so you grew up with wawa which was
like nicer and cleaner would you grow up
outside of philly gotcha so i love
philly yeah shout out to one of my
favorite favorite cities right here in
may nice two weeks go check them out
come on let's go yeah the helium
yeah yeah helium is great before we move
on too far from the car do you eat in
the ferrari never
you eat any of the cars the bronco maybe
the bronco i treat like uh like a hotel
i'll wipe my hands in the sheets that's
all right that's your that's you're
joking on the corner yeah yeah i like
those new broncos too brocco is so fun
that's your bomber you don't mind trash
that's that's my daddy wagon
my kids can go in the back and take the
top off they love it la it's [ __ ]
dope manchester take the top off yeah
it's cool what's the maintenance process
on the cars who's cleaning them are you
cleaning them on a saturday afternoon do
you have somebody to come in somebody
commented
somewhere how do you clean a ferrari
yeah i mean you can't just take that
porsche i clean myself and then the
other cars we have a service every
depends if if i'm not as busy i'll clean
all of them i love washing cars i grew
up washing cars i love doing it but if
it's busy we have a guy comes all right
but he doesn't touch the other cars yeah
okay
and that's pretty classy
have you ever microwaved bacon oh yeah
is that your go-to what's your preferred
method of cooking bacon uh in in the
frying pan like a goddamn gentleman of
course
thank you finally some sense to this guy
but my mom would we grew up on a
microwave oh yeah
disappointing good stuff
he does it it's exclusive
you have a favorite salad dressing
i mean i don't like salads and poppy
seed
okay
that's a first right there that's pretty
[ __ ] this guy can't get a read on
this guy that's pretty close that's from
a weird i mean he's got ostriches he's
getting
poppy seed salad dressing now when you
say you only eat red meat you're telling
me that like what what what would be a
typical dinner if you were home at the
house uh
i'll usually grill or order uh from
postmates but i'll grill like a filet or
a t-bone or something okay and just that
just that what kind of girl are we
talking what do you got what's the grill
traeger uh you know it's a viking grill
yeah it's all right the pool yeah
now the place is is it built in is there
like this built-in it's built like
there's the the hard rock around there
[ __ ]
my brother's got yeah it's pretty classy
it's pretty cloudy did you build this
house or did you guys buy it it was
already it was already there bought it
made some uh upgrades to it nice full
basketball court like full-size
basketball court in it or outside uh in
the backyard okay i think i'd say inside
my mind was gonna be long no not drake
i'm not i'm not doing that can we be
best friend
there's also cracks on the court yeah i
don't get twisted
i want my kids to be somewhat humble and
it's a chain neck yeah
don't forget where you [ __ ] came from
my son's like that we have chained
holy [ __ ] rucker park all right in
the kitchen
is it what what's the fridge sub z
viking what are you stainless steel
everything's viking yeah stainless steel
yeah yeah okay it's all right
washer and dryer in the house yeah
if it came with a basketball court not a
washer and dryer i'd be [ __ ] furious
there's no bathroom you don't realize
until it's like the first time
you got the polo field right out there
huh all right
his and her sinks in the bathroom and
he's got a [ __ ] basketball court yeah
he's got his inheritance
you [ __ ] idiot
i'd show the man some goddamn respect
they got a walk-in closet too i guess
do you yeah
he's probably got a closet for watches
this [ __ ] guy
do you have a lot of water so you have
windows
you see out the windows right
show the man some goddamn respect
damn that's awesome the hacky sack thing
keep going
um who cuts the grass you cutting the
grass yourself you got a landscaper
landscaper nice but i enjoy cutting
grass nothing makes nothing gives me
like throwback memories and like fresh
cut graphs do you have the mower there
too you have your own mower mower yeah
oh that's nice okay you got a toro what
are you rocking do you know man whatever
ferrari whatever home depot sells yeah
lamborghini
how to get on a list to get it you can't
just buy it it's a six year waiting list
it's a riding mower with a v12 yeah made
by lamborghini i got the grass in two
minutes it's awesome
it's a bentley yeah
will you sneak snacks into the movie
theater
no i buy them you buy them i grew up
sneaking snacks yeah yeah you still go
you go to the grocery store where you go
and you get the order for the week yeah
okay you hook the kids up with the
snacks they like and all that kind of
stuff yeah because i grew up on sugar
and i know especially where i live in
calabasas it's like
you know that's where you can't live
yeah the parents are worried about like
sugar and [ __ ] but i said i grew up on
sure clearly have an issue with it
because i won't get my cavities fixed
but
yeah i turned out all right yeah you're
killing it what are you talking about
after talking about this podcast i got
some major issues today
yeah there's some [ __ ] you got to go
back and dig into but you know all in
all you're doing all right for yourself
my therapist i'm like jesus christ
you sleep with your socks on
no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no i'd be insane if you didn't
yeah we're just checking i don't know he
almost hit you dude no no
my socks that's crazy
do you have sex with your socks on no
do you own any boot cut jeans
absolutely not okay did you ever own any
ed hardy stuff yes i had one ed hardy
shirt just one huh yeah just one really
what's the suit situation at the house
probably pretty proper the suit because
i used to work for a bravo knee so i
used to have to host the ground yeah
a lot of the oscars yeah and so they'd
make me all these tailored suits damn i
didn't have to pay for them though don't
get twisted that's still cool though
it's cool if you i guess if i have an
event to go to which i don't but i'll
look pretty cool if i do you know how to
tie a tie i presume yeah bow tie you tie
both no no those are so i can't wrap my
[ __ ] every wedding i go to i try it's
like a rubik's cube
insane dude um how do you sleep how many
pillows do you use when you sleep
minimum three pillows how do you do it
behind the head
one behind the head one over the eyes
hugging the other nice yeah yeah just
kidding sleep on my side he's a loose
cannon if you're a pillow hugger you got
issues yeah because i'm one myself more
anxiety oh yeah my anxiety's through the
roof yes
the booze helps with that
will you pee in the shower oh yeah right
in there oh yeah i'll do everything all
at once in the shower i'll pee in the
shower but i also might it's a bad
example for my son but i'll get out of
the car i got to pee i'll piss right in
our [ __ ] yard dude i'll pee wherever
really yeah there's something about
peeing outside
but no one can see it's not like the
neighbors can see you right yeah i mean
i was in venice the other day and i had
to be so bad i had to do this photo
shoot and i just pissed dude that's a
little bit like right behind groundworks
coffee on main street
and some guy walked by because i
appreciate the bugs there's so many bums
yeah like i'm doing you guys a favor
you're lucky you're gonna look at a real
one you're not one of these homeless
wieners spelling [ __ ] be cool man huh
but there's something about peeing
outside i feel like hell's angel yeah it
feels dicey it's really cool what's the
soap situation using a bar using uh
something fancy gel what do you got i
don't trust uh the three-in-one shampoo
body washing conditioner okay
it's insane i forgot my the the the it
smells good it's like a body wash and i
use a separate shampoo but it's like a
body wash you can use it to like clean
your tables too you don't talk about no
no it looks all weird
super old school i don't know yeah
it sounds like you're taking a shower
with [ __ ] and spam to be honest with you
basically yeah yeah i don't know it's my
favorite though you can clean the wood
with it yeah dude
you can mop your floors with it brush
your teeth what is that pledge yeah gets
paint off walls hmm
uh
have you ever worn a kangal hat
listen man
hey hey really i love you boss i love
you guys you guys seem like good guys
are my favorite but not get the [ __ ] off
the hacky sack
strike one the socks strike two
the kangol hat no i don't have it out i
don't have one see where we stand next
question have you ever owned a fubu
shirt
what is happening right now
do you have a high school class ring and
if so did you wear it no never got one
okay i had a big 12 championship ring in
college there you go never wore it
though my dad still has he's sweet he's
holding it hostage that's great did you
wear your uh letterman jacket in high
school yeah hell yeah roll around
that was my batman outfit
uh hmm do you remember how old were you
the first time you had lobster
[ __ ]
older older right yeah really yeah yeah
lobster
you like to go out to expensive dinners
now you go out to a nice dinner now i do
yeah yeah so it's that that's one thing
i will do yeah especially especially
when on the road like with my team like
everybody works so hard if if we have
time we'll go to a good dinner tomahawk
steaks
whatever they want nice yeah you ever
been to salt bay's place or anything
like that i've been a salt base really
basalt bay is in la did he come to the
table and do the thing here's the thing
about that he's he you know he i think
he's in miami full-time so he opened
this place up and uh
i hate to go about it the steak was [ __ ]
dude and it was so expensive and the guy
comes to the table he goes do you want a
gold-plated stuff i heard yeah we were
talking about this
discovery we think it's whack dude it
was i don't know the stick i was like
1100 bucks
why would i want [ __ ] gold yeah no
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up all right you mean
foil [ __ ] yeah yeah no i don't
hold the aluminum foil and here's the
thing i hate like attention if i'm not
on stage i don't want any attention oh
yeah i do not want this i want to be
invisible most of the time yeah so this
place is like such a scene which i hate
so i'm already on edge i'm there with my
wife and her her friends it's actually
my son's best friend's parents who who
we love but we're all there and when you
order a steak
it's like you know when you do red
robin's your birthday and you go who's
birthday here
they do it for everybody so this [ __ ]
guy this like
fake salt bait comes the table
with salt dude like a huge thing of salt
and he throws it on the steak and it
goes everywhere all i'm like what in the
[ __ ]
and then he cuts it and they're filming
it of course there's some [ __ ] dweeb
there filming it and then it goes defeat
it's not happening dude yeah
where are we i can't i can't be on
camera i'm not gonna i'm not gonna deep
throat this time
oh i asked him i went hey dude if i come
here again can i pay you not to do this
yes can you just give me my food that's
insane yeah it's a spectacle is it chuck
e cheese dude what are you doing here um
all right i got one for you we're
speaking of restaurants are big here
going out to dinner especially now that
we're making a couple of bucks we you
know you guys are balling we're trying
to twist we're trying to figure it out
we feel like i'm the only one selling
tickets no no no no we're
we've had an amazing year but like let's
say you know you were just with uh
schultzy you say or you know even
christy d saying say you and schultzy go
out to dinner right just you two
checks how's that check being handled
i'll i'll pay for it every time yeah
every time yeah yeah okay no no split
because you know he's gonna also watch
as soon as the waiter comes like if it's
around like i can tell he's done i'll
just give him my card don't even look at
the check that's really classy right
there i always pay yeah i never expect
anybody to pay if you get to a place and
you sit down will you change tables
no i just take it yeah it could be the
shittiest seat in the house i'll just
take it you call it your manager or
somebody call ahead and say hey we want
a private room or something like that or
you just roll in i the only time i ever
had to flex like that which is the
biggest [ __ ] move was is my girl's
birthday and her favorite restaurant
this is actually last saturday they were
like booked for three months and that's
the only time i hit up my manager like
dude you gotta figure something yeah
call in a favor come on you gotta you
gotta do it your girl's birthday baby
what are you kidding me but bro this is
in hollywood and they're robbing people
down there and [ __ ] so i'm stressed out
my anxiety's insane phyllis so i'm on
you tried to take the bronco to that one
yeah
don't pull up in the [ __ ] no my girl
want to drive the ferrari oh my god
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
if you don't see the news i know you
watch telemundo i'd see it on telemundo
it's all over she's mexican so uh we
pull up there my anxiety is through the
[ __ ] roof the security guy comes out
and he's like you know big fan man and
so i'm like oh this guy that's my comedy
right and he's taking us up there and
he's like if i can do anything i loved
you on the bills yeah
when he goes you know he's like a huge
fan man we got you when's the next fight
it's about to be right now
to tune you up for the appetizers yeah
i'm insulting this hey [ __ ] i do six
shows a week yeah one pocket
i don't know yeah that's tough well
here's the thing i i you know i wanted
to tip him he took care of us got us to
see anything and i only had this isn't a
flex brogan paid me for doing this show
relax we don't want you to fly you know
we had a million dollar bill on me
dude i only had i only had hundreds on
me so i got hey i appreciate it and i
was like oh yeah have a good day it's
already out of chains yeah yeah
let me get a five back
yeah what is the tip situation i imagine
it's probably usually pretty hefty
you throw down i'll throw down and uh
like if i do the sets at the comment
store laugh actor improv any cash they
give me i always give to the door guys
or guys yeah i've never take i've never
took payment in la for shows yeah that's
good when i very first started when i
need the money at that time i'd always
give it to the door guys or up and
coming comics yeah you got to take care
of those door guys at the clubs for sure
yeah you got to get a complete hustle if
you don't yeah well you take leftovers
home from the restaurant very rare
mm-hmm
listen dude you eat it i eat it yeah if
you don't like it i'm not eating it i'm
not taking it home even if i don't like
it i mean like on my special the green
girl poppy you know i was shot in
october man time was 270 pounds like i
get big if i don't watch it now i'm like
245 on the car good you're trim yeah and
that gringo poppy is all thick
he's up there sweating baby i had to
edit that thing myself
dude watching or listening to yourself
how come somebody was like hey bro do
you want you think you want to lose some
weight in the face yeah i like [ __ ]
awful dude
it's tough
yeah no sweating non-stop
you have a preferred eggs benedict do
you like eggs benedict no not for me
really what's your normal breakfast if
you're going out to breakfast i fast i
like i guess i haven't eaten a single
thing today and it is
7 30 here i usually fast so i do all my
shows in the morning so i fast i'll
again i have eight shots of espresso i
have two coffees before i leave the
house and get eight shots of espresso
then i'll have like a rain energy drink
while i do the podcast i'm telling you
enjoy enjoy the company
four years of this [ __ ] so i'm gonna die
any second but uh i usually don't eat to
about two o'clock so i haven't had
breakfast i don't know how long okay bam
bro you have weaponized anxiety
yeah my anxiety isn't charging it up
every morning yeah
it's it's sick honestly it's [ __ ]
working dude yeah thanks man you keep
any magazines in the bathroom
uh i always bring i i do have a uh
membership me i like old school [ __ ] so
like i don't subscribe to social media i
have it i post and go so you want sure
you've had people on the go i posting
ghosts i haven't seen a comment or
anything in probably three to four years
okay i don't see anything i [ __ ] got
let's go
i don't subscribe to that stuff but i do
like i you know doing what i do i always
have something to talk about and have
opinion on it so i have all the
newspapers and magazines so i'll bring
that into the bathroom but i don't have
them in the bathroom they all get
delivered to the house all the papers
nice
not too bad it's all right do you snore
i'm sure
look at me yeah and i had no surgery too
i uh when i was a ufc fight i had my
nose shattered by merkel crow cop
through an elbow and it shattered my
nose in like 70 different places so that
they go up there and fix it give me a
nose job still can't breathe i'm a
little overweight let's be fair so i'm
sure i snore
yeah i feel like a breath right strip
might help okay yeah i tried them they
don't work for me
i'm a mouth breather though me too and
so it's like my mouth is always dry yeah
this is the first water i've had in
years yeah
you guys have any espresso what's going
on dude i drink 12 diet coke
12 diet cokes a day i'm a big dc guy
myself yeah i can't get enough i think
we're best friends you me and trump
buddy
cause he's in good shape yeah
uh have you ever owned a butterfly knife
oh yeah
now we're getting to the good stuff yeah
numb chucks chinese stars on [ __ ]
charlie would buy it for me yeah
charlie for sure uncle charlie he's a
truck driver full sleeve tattoos that's
why i have tattoos grandpa had full
sleeves he has full sleeves your grandpa
had full sleeves
generational dirt bags
yeah they're both truck drivers hardcore
dudes military my entire family's
military but back to the butter knives
he would uh
if you remember back in the day the
magazines would have them you could call
it yeah i don't know why the worst
customer service in the world it would
take 12 weeks
yeah i would forget dude i'm forgetting
to show them like oh [ __ ] when we order
[ __ ] brass knuckles
i'm 11.
yeah that's awesome yeah don't let my
brother get all of these yeah
i mean
uncle charlie do you have any other
anyone in your family who call by not
their name why not like you oh yeah it's
a british thing so uh aunt nubby aunt
nelby
you call her nub
nupster
did she have ham yeah
that'd be offensive if she did it and
i'll be she
is fantastic she was almost the mom to
us like she was the one that watched
this baby sis when i was a kid would buy
us burger king every day
shout out tonight she didn't have the
money to buy his burger king would
burger king be your preferred fast food
all day dude i'll argue anybody in here
dude a whopper with cheese and ketchup
only name a better [ __ ] fast food
burger daddy i think we're about to get
into it boys
big man big man's a mcdonald's guy what
do you do what are you
what are you a quarter pounder fan
[Laughter]
a royale with cheese what are you like
quarter patterns fatty
when you come out with the big mac what
do you got man i have a lot of respect
i'm gonna tell you right now
i have a lot of respect for the whopper
a lot of respect you gotta but i might
mine would always 100 come with a lot of
mayonnaise
are you not a mayonnaise guy no sir at
all at all hate it
hate it hate it disgusting
i'm a big horseradish guy whoa but but
like real [ __ ] spicy horseradish just
straight like not like in a cream sauce
or something uh if you put you know you
make cocktail sauce with uh ketchup and
uh cocktail 100 i put the most
horseradish meat too i love it i like it
to burn the senses well you do make me
feel a lot well you do oysters you like
oysters on the half to the max on
everything i know yeah oh everything's
so intense
[Laughter]
that might be where the anxiety is
coming from yeah i love it though the
nicotine helps as well with anxiety yeah
oh yeah it's i mean i'm going to chain
smoke your anxiety gives me gets my
anxiety going now
i went to mexico i didn't sleep a
[ __ ] wink because i i read all the
news i get all those papers and they're
trying to scare you with cartel and
kidnappings so my girl's like go to bed
i'm like i can't i can't it's almost got
to be on the lookout yeah i was like
who's going to watch the [ __ ] kids
and also kidnappings through the roof
she's like who the [ __ ] kidnapping
your big yeah no [ __ ] who's coming in
also yeah i'd be like robin batman's
house
are you kidding me you drive out to a
waterfall or something
huh
i got a couple more here but i think
what do you got man
i mean i could do this all night by the
way
have you ever owned cargo sweatpants
yes in high school yeah they were they
were able to yeah before i knew they
were racist if you watched that that was
a wild documentary how do you feel about
surprise parties i hate them
i'd imagine
lights off people jumping out and
scaring you
that's how i that's how i killed that
my ct flares up man i don't like that uh
have you ever had a manicure
no i've had a pedicure on my foot
because i've ingrown toenail that's
that's medicinal the asian girl kept
going oh you bit big feet big feet what
size shoe you're rocking 13 13 wide
do you have name brand luggage
uh is a way named yeah that's probably
was it a sponsor at some point or no no
oh okay yeah i got show time so well i
used to work for showtime i left them
started my own company but i used to
work showtime for five years and they
would for uh christmas send me luggage
that said showtime on it there you go
pretty good and that's what you're using
yeah so you're you're currently using
branded free luggage yeah it's trashy
ever have an earring yeah
never no earrings never no earrings all
right and if you had pizza i know you
keep it tight but if you had pizza do
you eat your crust or not eat the crust
i definitely eat the crust i don't know
all right i'll get a side of marinara
and dip it in the [ __ ] yeah okay
that checks out my favorite pizza in new
york is uh prince french pizza okay
that's good it's good now you've you're
joe's man typically you guys are gonna
hate me for this but you're not from new
york so be cool
hey man whatever you say yeah nobody
hates you
you're among friends here yeah i mean
you brothers we invited him everybody
hates you
we love you
we're having a nice time yeah take it
easy man
this was a little better
that's all i said man i just said i
prefer the milkshakes to shake shack i
just said the best western's best
slightly better man be cool
say motel six [ __ ] motel figs
[Laughter]
are you sunglass man i like some here's
the thing about sunglasses uh lasik uh
vision correction uh-huh one of the side
effects is your eyes are super sensitive
to light there you go so i do a show
called food truck diaries and it's
outside people like oh you think you're
[ __ ] nicholas cage with sunglass all
the time
no i can't see in the light so i have to
have sunglasses on and at night one of
the bad things too you gotta correct it
at night
everything's kind of blurry so it i just
figured there's fog all the time in l.a
i didn't know there's not fog this guy's
driving in a [ __ ] smoke storm
at 100 miles an hour
in a [ __ ] ferrari anxiety ferrari and
eight shots of espresso
on 15 lattes
[Music]
playing the instruments
[Music]
i wish
anyone in your family ever represent
themselves in court
i've been saving that one for like six
months dude
absolutely not sorry
[Laughter]
can you whistle yeah can you whistle
with your fingers no i wish i could i
winked both eyes
uh oh like this yeah yeah it's pretty
good that's pretty good um double
jointed anything like that i
wish i feel like it was cool it was cool
like elementary you're bloody like
yeah like holy [ __ ] it was hot yeah
that's been
can you name any of the guys from pawn
stars
oh
i watched that show when it's not from
time to time i always want to buy stuff
i know right i'd like to go in and buy
like can i have that samurai
[ __ ] trash
yeah
she's watching yeah pawn stores are
going i'll get that [ __ ] samurai
sword in the back
[Laughter]
you have a man cave at the house
uh the yeah it sounds like i'm right we
have a theater it came with a movie
theater so all my comedy stuff like
pictures at the store and the improv
yeah it's all framed and like my special
posters are there that's great then you
know my uh heroes are like jim carrey
and adam sandler have cool paintings of
adam sandlin jim carrey nice you have
any paintings of yourself in the house
no sir
uh my girl might have some in the garage
for my fight days okay that's yeah
absolutely you walked in the house you
won't know i fought like i put all that
stuff in the garage no trophies or
anything like that laying around
okay
all right they don't give trophies it's
pretty good he's a real interesting it's
not little weak
it's belt you [ __ ] idiot
trophies yeah here's your medal brendan
no there's no trophy hey my name fell
off what's going on here just my fourth
grade pop warner yeah i'm pretty proud
of that he's an interesting mix
tell you that i i mean i i have i'm
ready to render my
yeah you had a big bird and you didn't
know what kind it was and you kept it in
the closet
you would do dine and dash with your mom
you wore spikes to class yeah it's crazy
but you're put together i'm sure the
house is probably spotless all the time
oh yeah yeah yeah you keep everything
because of tonight
you do everything nice yeah you're doing
well it's great you're on [ __ ]
hardware it's i [ __ ] [ __ ] love it
yeah it's great but yeah you're garbage
you're
[Laughter]
mcgregor cleats i think that's where it
went south yeah you didn't start yeah
you weren't starting off strong man if i
was in elementary school and saw a kid
walk in with cleats i don't know i think
i'd move schools or something yeah jesus
christ yeah set some records fellas
brendan schaub everybody man i mean how
many people have you had on here that
aren't trash
that's that's kind of a load of cut your
story was insane yeah that's a proper
wild one yeah yeah i mean we've
definitely had wild stories but like
front to back i mean just from like
the stories as a childhood then you've
you're an accomplished fighter you
walked onto the [ __ ] bills you're a
successful podcaster and stand-up
comedian like you've rea you're like the
forest gump of [ __ ] you know
entertainment that's crazy same iq
that's what's crazy babe
this whole career is make a wish yeah
love you guys so much go watch the
special go watch the special anything
else you want to let the folks out there
know special the gringo poppy it's on uh
my own youtube thick boy uh youtube is
the channel it's on there now it's all
shot edited everything's my team we all
did everything ourselves [ __ ] the way
to go is [ __ ] [ __ ] all these [ __ ]
yeah i mean do it yourself baby i'll be
in uh charlotte this thursday friday
saturday at the comedy zone and then uh
philly is after that billy go out and
see this philly go see him man
check it out kippy what do you got for
same thing check us out on the road
thanks for listening we [ __ ]
appreciate everything what an episode
buddy we love you thank you thank you
man we love you we'll see you next week
peace